Ford wants to define the future of
self-driving cars in the city where the
company had its humble beginnings
executive chairman Bill Ford jr. just
laid out plans to turn a century old
Detroit train station into its new hub
for autonomous and electric vehicles we
showed you yesterday how the building
one of Detroit's oldest neighborhoods
will soon house 2,500 employees only on
CBS this morning the great-grandson of
company founder that's Henry Ford shares
the future of self-driving technology
his take on Trump administration tariffs
and competition from Silicon Valley this
isn't just another old building this is
we want to take an old building and
inject new life into it and I think we
have words you'd expect more from a real
estate developer than the head of one of
the world's biggest car companies look
at the columns I like that but real
estate is very much on the mind of
Ford's executive chairman Bill Ford jr.
these days specifically this real estate
the derelict ruins of Detroit's 105 year
old Michigan central train station we're
gonna define the future of autonomous
driving here in this building now the
building will become the new hub affords
autonomous and electric vehicle teams I
heard somebody say don't call it the
train station call it the brain station
that bill or jr. is planning to give
Silicon Valley a run for its money in
terms of recruiting really smart people
to come here we are it's a market some
say Ford has already lost to competitors
like General Motors in Google's way mow
unit companies that are promising to
have autonomous cars on roads by later
this year or early next Ford predicts
its self-driving models won't be ready
until 2021 some people say that you're
already behind the ball - that you don't
know it's just mothers are coming out
before you they're coming out with
statements there's been a lot of
over-promising and I think a lot of
misinformation that's been out there
it's really important that we get it
right rather than get it quickly another
competitor Tesla CEO Elon Musk has
openly criticized legacy Detroit
automakers like Ford for being stuck in
the past
and yet last week after announcing that
he was laying off nine percent of his
white-collar work force musk appeared to
seek common ground Elon Musk tweeted
recently that Tesla and Ford remained
the only American car companies who
haven't gone bankrupt true I've always
been impressed by him
I think he's finding that maybe building
a car company is more difficult than he
first thought it might be could it be
that Tesla and Ford have a lot more in
common than most of us realize or think
oh absolutely
I think the similarities are much
greater than the differences frankly
these days all American auto companies
are dealing with President Trump's
decision to slap tariffs on imported
steel and aluminum something many
analysts expect will raise the cost of
making a car when you heard that was
coming did that freak you out a little
bit we didn't freak me out but I don't
think it's helpful there eighty times
more jobs attached to people who use
steel like airplanes and autos and than
people who make steel and those users
will be disadvantaged by these tariffs
because the prices because the domestic
where everything's gonna rise one price
tag Ford will not discuss is how much he
paid for this building did you get it
for a steal we got a really good I'm
trying to find out how much about
Detroit real estate experts have
estimated the total cost to buy and
renovate the station will run well into
hundreds of millions of dollars for Bill
Ford that's money well spent to position
his 115 year old company for the future
a future where not everyone will own and
drive their own cars but rather share
ones that drive themselves but is a very
good money for the company no I think
it'll be much better business model for
us because explain well in this future
model of autonomous vehicles it'll be a
subscription rate potentially and it'll
be a recurring revenue model for us but
your last name is forward right no
disrespect to your great grandfather but
do you think he would be turning over in
his grave right now as he knew because
he used to say everybody should own a
car course he did but I think a little
bit deeper what he really did was he
enabled people to move freely that was
his goal was to give people the the
freedom of movement
I think my great-grandfather would love
this because it's redefining what it
means to move in the world Henry Ford's
great-grandson is not afraid to shake
things up earlier this year he
discontinued almost every Ford sedan
line in North America focusing instead
on trucks and SUVs he's insisting those
trucks are becoming more fuel-efficient
and soon will be available in hybrid and
electric versions it's an environmental
focus he says he discovered long before
his industry did when you first started
talking about this in the company
electric vehicles and self-driving
vehicles were you well received not
always when I joined the board I was
actually told that I shouldn't associate
with any known or suspected
environmentalist and of course I paid no
attention to that and I did but you know
it's been a hard journey because often
the technology wasn't there to deliver
you actually had to decide if you were
going to join the family business what
was the struggle for you well look you
know my dad was great because he said to
me look you're not gonna be doing
yourself or the company any favors if
your heart isn't it and so I thought all
right I'll try it I'll see how it goes
your heart in it yeah you bet it is yeah
I love this I make that l.o.v.e
exclamation point capital letters he
clearly loves a company he loves the
city you know he's predicting or hoping
that it'll be done by 2022 but you know
with any construction he said Bill you
need to double that but he feels pretty
good about how it's well I like how
they're not just innovating to just in
terms of the company but they're trying
to help the city around them and those
heroes can be complimentary thanks those
can make up and that matters a lot to
him nor I said are you trying it when he
said you know they're releasing
statements I said who are you talking
about specifically goes nod I want to
give him that well give me some initials
no he didn't want to give that said well
do you want to beat Elon Musk he goes I
want to beat Elon Musk and everybody in
this business or he wasn't throwing a
specific shade no throwing general shade
but I can't wait to go back
I can't yeah I know incredible building
yes I would love to be there